j'espère qu'il veillera aussi sur les
fabricants de jouets du jura à qui je
veux rendre un hommage appuyé je les ai
reçus comme vous le savez il y a une
dizaine de jours smoby je rage ou et les
fabricants de jouets en bois du jura qui
perpétue une tradition séculaire de
fabrication de jouets dans votre
département
et je sais comme chacun d'entre vous ici
à quel point la situation est dure pour
eux ils font 60 70 % de leur chiffre
d'affaires les dernières semaines qui
précèdent noël
ils n'attendent qu'une seule chose c'est
de pouvoir rouvrir et vendre leurs
jouets croyez moi avec le premier
ministre avec le président de la
république nous faisons le maximum pour
que cette réouverture puisse avoir lieu
dans les meilleures conditions
sanitaires possibles et dès que les
conditions sanitaires le permettront
mais vous interroger sur le black friday
comme vous le savez c'est une opération
commerciale privée le ministre de
l'économie et des finances peut décaler
les dates de sol parce que c'est une
opération qui est dans les mains des
pouvoirs publics
en revanche à sète une opération
commerciale privée mais j'ai toujours
rappelé dans cet hémicycle et ailleurs
que nous ne gagnerons la bataille contre
le virus et que nous gagnerons la
bataille économique que si chacun fait
preuve de sens des responsabilités la
responsabilité ça peut pas être
uniquement pour la puissance publique et
pas pour la puissance privée c'est pour
tout le monde tout le temps surtout en
période de crise et donc je voudrais
appeler tous les acteurs économiques que
ce soit la grande distribution que ce
soient des acteurs du commerce digital
au sens des responsabilités en posant
cette simple question est ce que
vraiment vendredi prochain c'est la
bonne date pour organiser un black
friday
ma réponse est non et j'espère qu'ils me
comprendront aussi j'aurai l'occasion de
leur en parler pour leur demander de
faire preuve de sens des responsabilités
et examiner toutes les possibilités de
décaler cette opération qui n'a pas de
sens dans les circonstances actuelles
merci
[Musique]